it was not too long ago back at CES in
January of 2014 that valves unveiled its
plans to develop these steam machines
which is supposed to bring pc gaming
into the living room and that's a pretty
complicated thing but valve has thought
through some of those problems and our
products including a steam controller
and the steam link a device that sends
the video and the controls from your pc
to the TV are almost on the market and
i'm here with mary we're going to take a
look at some of these products we have
first of all the new steam controller
which offers some interesting inputs for
people that overcomes the hurdles when
you don't have a keyboard which is
interesting because this is we've seen
multiple iterations of this but this is
like the final retail product that we're
going to see on the market when you buy
this exactly yeah I think people can get
them if they pre-ordered they're going
to be getting them within the next week
or two otherwise it's going to be on the
market in November so let's open it up
alright let's do it one do it sure
alright here we go this is the final
game pad ooh it's really amazing to see
like you were saying about the touchpad
controls it's fascinating because in the
iterations we saw maybe not as nice of a
plastic as this final product didn't
have the different finish and you know
it feels really good it feels a lot
better than the original iteration that
people were getting the buttons have
some nice depth to them and and the
touchpad feels much more sensitive to
your controls and it's really great to
them is they're also buttons right so
not only can you move your fingers
around the touch pads but they all click
as well and you also have buttons on the
back as well yeah it's sort of similar
to the new xbox one like elite
controller the hundred fifty dollars
thing that's coming up there of course
is one analog stick and that is used you
know for games that we're used to
speaking the valve last week they told
me that pretty much any game that uses
the Xbox input control scheme will adapt
to this very easily but they're also
making it really easy through steam
itself to provide an interface lets you
remap not controls but actions to the
controller which is slightly different
from assigning a button to an action in
I know this also comes with two double A
batteries and these provide believe it
or not 80 hours of gameplay that's
according to valve which is really
significant that that's really freaking
high I have no idea how they pulled it
off and we obviously have to test that
to see that's accurate and there is the
little wireless dongle this uses a
proprietary RF radio signal so you will
need this to use the steam controller it
will not work with other bluetooth
dongles or any other radios you may have
this is something valve has developed
especially for the controller there's a
lot of button inputs on these
controllers now from the shoulders the
triggers but back part buttons and then
the actual touchpad themselves being
buttons what's me really fascinating to
see is how the community maps these
individually for particular games you
might find for a game like shovel Knight
they'll be completely differently mapped
you for precision platformer than it
would for a shooter or something like
that so you're gonna see a lot of input
from the community which I think will be
really fascinating on how to use this
per game and valve said they may be
rewarding people with certain badges
that contribute to that effort but
meanwhile for games that support it
there will be an icon that clearly
indicates that this game supports the
steam controller really well if a game
does not have great support valve will
also point that out so you understand
what you're getting yourself into it's a
very clear warning and lets it be known
that you're gonna have to reconfigure
this or find another alternative so
moving on from the controller which I'll
leave open down here we're going into
the steam link now this is a little box
that you connect on your TV and what
this does is it allows you to send both
inputs end video to and fro from your PC
to your TV so that way you're not
dangling like really long hdmi cables
are really long controller cords to get
that to work and the reason it sends
input back is so that you can actually
plug in your steam controller all right
so there's a few inputs here already we
can see it's a actually pretty heavy
it's pretty concentrated for what it is
yeah it's a hefty little guy and you
know this is sort of solving one of the
bigger issues which is you know
connecting to devices that are really
far away there are alternatives out
there for video services like the
chromecast or Apple's AirPlay but but
this actually solves something
had not been addressed before which is
you know sending everything you need for
a game you know from a high-powered
system but of course if you don't
already have a pc and you want to get
into the steam machine you know you just
want to start enjoying that you can buy
one from a company like alienware last
year they came out with the alienware
alpha pc which is a really small pc that
had sort of the dual boot OS so let you
use steam OS which has the the steam a
UI built into it or windows for
traditional gaming because not
everything is supported under steam OS
right out of the box but this is the
alienware as latest version and let's
take a look now it to comes with a
controller valve does have control over
who calls their machine a steam machine
and one of the rules is that it has to
include a controller but people can
choose to buy it if they wish without it
but they need to have the option to
purchase that yeah and there are some or
batteries and cables but really let's
just look at the Alpha because it's a
very tiny pc that starts around four
hundred and fifty dollars and even those
base configs are pretty good it's based
off of a nvidia 860 em mobile GPU it's
been slightly modified it's got most of
them have gddr5 ram and up to a terabyte
of hard drive space and I bleed 8 to 16
gigs of system memory this thing is
small is cheap but it does compare
pretty well to console games last year
we did a benchmark series sort of
comparing it to consoles games like
shadow of mordor watchdogs and the like
it actually performed quite a bit on
part and we think about it it's a really
good deal because the pc is so versatile
it has such a big game library and
what's the retail price for this packet
right so this one starts in at 450 and i
believe it goes all the way up to eight
hundred dollars but ultimately what you
have here is a very tiny portable pc
that's made for gaming and is pretty
good you're not going to get the high
end graphics that everyone loves and you
know really argues is the reason for PC
gaming in the first place but again you
have a massive library of games a very
flexible system and something that works
perfectly in valves new steam machine
ecosystem now looking between these
three pieces it looks like they're
trying to give you pretty much an
all-in-one system for gaming on your TV
with their own individual control
I think it's really fascinating kind of
jump in on that so they're kind of
trying to go all or nothing in here and
what's really fascinating is that
they're using the community kind of to
test out their systems they've
reiterated it throughout the process and
now even with that there's different
versions of this pc based on input from
the community and there's going to be a
lot of other steam machines as well
there are a lot of companies making
these so you're going to see them from
yeah there's probably to be more than a
dozen at launch maybe this fall mmm so
you'll need to check back with us we'll
be doing a lot more testing to see how
these actually perform and run not just
the pc but the controller as well see
this is actually as functional as we
hope it is it's supposed to be used for
all sorts of games you know everything
from civilization to Street Fighter to a
first-person shooter but how well it
works that remains to be seen so yeah
stay tuned morphol gamespot
you